salve a tutti questi due bambini giocano
in spiaggia sembra una situazione
normale e se vi dicessi che il bambino a
destra e non vedente allora
probabilmente il vostro modo di vedere
questa foto cambierebbe e vi chiedo
quanto sarebbe bello poter continuare a
vedere questa foto come la guardavate
prima pensando che non ci siano ostacoli
tra i due bambini nel giocare insieme
molti di noi sono genitori
io per esempio due bambini che mi
aspettano a casa altri sono fratelli
altri ancora sono amici di bambini i
bambini sono un dono importante e siamo
tutti d'accordo
ogni giorno imparano tantissime
informazioni e le informazioni che
imparano ogni giorno gli servono per
crescere
pensiamo al nostro primo ricordo può
essere un ricordo bello può essere un
ricordo brutto comunque sia appartiene
alla nostra infanzia è avvenuto
tantissimi anni fa e ancora ce lo
ricordiamo
e quindi vi chiedo voi non sareste
arrabbiati perché io sono molto
arrabbiata a pensare che la maggior
parte della tecnologia che c'è a
disposizione per persone non vedenti non
sia adatta ai bambini i bambini non
possono usarla non è pensata per loro io
sono molto arrabbiata sono anche
dispiaciuta
ed è per questo che sono qua oggi a
raccontarvi del mio desiderio
il desiderio di far sì che
quell'immagine quel momento che abbiamo
visto nella prima slide avvenga è per
quello che giorno dopo giorno lavoro con
le neuroscienze con la tecnologia per
riuscire a creare delle nuove soluzioni
tecnologiche per bambini che non vedono
questo è il mio desiderio
io sono una psicologa di formazione che
però nel suo percorso ha conosciuto la
tecnologia
ecco non sono una psicologa come quelle
che potete immaginare che ascoltano i
problemi degli altri non sono una vera
psicologa quello che faccio si può
chiamare una via di mezzo tra psico
tecnologia techno psicologia chiamata
era un po come volete ma questo nuovo
incontro ha permesso di vedere al
problema della disabilità vittima in un
modo nuovo
ci sono tanti dispositivi a disposizione
per persone non vedenti
io credo che il problema principale di
tutti questi strumenti è che sono troppo
complessi e per questo non vengono usati
e credo che la soluzione a questo
problema si possa riassumere in tre
punti che sono intervenire presto capire
il cervello e creare sistemi che siano
semplici immediati e naturali questo è
un dispositivo che viene usato dalla
bers da persone non vedenti
ci sono degli occhialini che vengono
indossati
una telecamera che rileva le
informazioni visive che traduce
l'informazione ad un computer
il computer interpreta l'informazione e
la trasforma in suoni non so se avete
presente come comunicano tra loro i
delfini o le balene il linguaggio che
arriva al non vedente assomiglia molto
al linguaggio delle balene e delfini
come potete immaginare non è proprio
semplice da interpretare da comprendere
vi garantisco che le persone non vedenti
dopo un lungo apprendimento imparano ad
interpretare questo segnale quindi
iniziano a vedere ma per i bambini è
impossibile è troppo complesso questo è
un altro strumento di nuovo abbiamo una
telecamera che viene montata su degli
occhiali la telecamera rileva
l'informazione visiva che viene
trasferita a un computer che la traduce
in segnali che vengono prodotti nella
lingua e vi chiedo se la persona volesse
parlare
no perché succede di voler parlare con
gli altri ecco qua la lingua è impegnata
oltre ad essere troppo complessi
richiedono anche troppa attenzione in
più non sono riabilitativi
ma sono sostitutivi questo vuol dire che
la persona una volta che ha imparato ad
usarli deve continuare ad usarle per
tutta la vita
non ne può più fare a meno ecco io credo
che siano questi i problemi per il quale
l'accettazione è veramente bassa ma
pensiamo quali sono i sistemi più usate
non vedenti a me me ne vengono in mente
due il braille e il bastone il braille
è stato creato nel 1829 ovvero 200 anni
fa ed è ancora uno degli strumenti
maggiormente usati possiamo dire di un
nuovo e fatto passi da gigante
voi che ne dite ma mentre un po come
funziona il braille che cosa mai il
brive e il bastone perché sono così
particolari io credo che sia perché la
persona manda un segnale e riceve un
segnale
il cervello è il protagonista proviamo a
fare un esempio
muovete il vostro dito sulla vostra
gamba siate voi a decidere quanto
muoverlo velocemente e siate voi a
capire se state toccando un paio di
jeans con dei pantaloni di velluto
questo perché l'informazione tappe che è
passata sotto il vostro dito è stata
interpretata e capita dal vostro
cervello il brive funziona così è la
persona che fa il movimento ed
informazione tattile che passa sotto dal
vito che dice alla persona non vedente
cosa sta leggendo
ed è proprio per questo che funziona
perché è molto semplice molto naturale
pensiamo al bastone bastone funzionano
allo stesso modo anche in questo caso la
persona muove il bastone quindi manda
lei il comando motorio e ascolta il
suono che viene prodotto dal bastone e
questo aiuta informazioni su come si sta
muovendo di nuovo è il cervello il
protagonista
io credo che sia proprio questa la
chiave la chiave sia quella di creare
dei sistemi che siano naturali ed
immediati che non richiedano un lungo
apprendimento
il training l'apprendimento deve essere
da vita di tutti i giorni
ascoltare un suono che viene dallo
spazio o sentire una stimolazione
tattile è qualcosa che siamo abituati a
fare il giorno dopo giorno e solo in
questo modo mettendo il cervello il
nostro cervello
il piano è possibile arrivare al bambino
seguendo questa strada
noi abbiamo dal 2005 iniziato un nuovo
percorso
l'idea principale è quella di studiare
il cervello quindi partire da capire
come funziona il cervello per arrivare a
creare una una nuova tecnologia
la maggior parte le tecnologie che ci
sono a disposizione fanno l'inverso
ovvero prima sviluppare la tecnologia e
solo successivamente la provano sulle
persone non vedenti o in generale sulle
persone io credo che sia importante
partire all inverso ovvero prima capire
cos'è come funziona il nostro cervello e
da lì sviluppare la tecnologia
vi racconterò come abbiamo fatto per
cominciare sfaterò un mito prendete un
oggetto qualsiasi che avete accanto a
voi che può essere mettetelo davanti ai
vostri occhi
se lo guardate e lo toccate in
contemporanea
se avete più di 8 10 anni di età
scuserete entrambe queste informazioni
ovvero mettete insieme visione tatto
tuttavia se avete meno di 8 10 anni di
età mi dispiace dirvelo ma userete solo
una modalità alla volta che sarà con
quella visiva o quella tattile già
perché abbiamo dimostrato per la prima
volta che i bambini fino a 8 10 anni di
età non riescono ad integrare
informazioni multisensoriali
adesso sfaterà un altro mito quante
volte vi è capitato di sentire che le
persone non vedenti abbiano una capacità
per sviluppata a sentire informazioni
uditive tattili
lo so è logico pensarlo quando una molla
in una modalità sensoriali non funziona
allora le altre
sviluppano di più purtroppo abbiamo
dimostrato
e di nuovo sono stati prima dimostrarlo
che questo non è sempre vero in assenza
di una modalità senso reale come la
visione anche le altre modalità
sensoriali come per esempio quella
tattile sono compromesse
quindi non è vero che in assenza di
visione l'udito è più sviluppato o
almeno dipende dal tipo di compito che
la persona fa questo nuovo approccio ci
permette cioè permesso di capire di
ribaltare il problema riguardava sotto
un'altra ottica
dobbiamo agire in modo naturale
immediato se la visione è importante per
capire lo spazio allora il bambino non
vedente potrebbe usare un suono al posto
della visione per capire lo spazio
questa intuizione è quella che ci ha
permesso di sviluppare questo
dispositivo
provate a muovere la mano davanti a voi
e guardate la mentre la muovete state
muovendo la mano quindi sentite nella
state muovendo e la vedete muovere
adesso chiudete gli occhi e muovete di
nuovo la mano sentite la mano a muoversi
la potete anche vedere
spero di no perchè se non avete
sbirciato
se adesso io riposizionarsi un suono nel
braccio e mi chiedesse di muovere di
nuovo la mano sempre ad occhi chiusi
voi potreste sentire il suono che si
sposta in questo modo potreste avere
un'informazione spaziale datata hanno
udito un informazione che nel bambino
vedente è data dalla vista il vostro
cervello sentirà il suono che si sposta
e capirà in questo modo come messo il
suo corpo nello spazio
abbiamo usato questo sistema i bambini
non vedenti e grazie a questo sistema
li ho visti correre giocare a nascondino
a giocare a palla questo sistema
funziona un po come il brive e come il
bastone perché la persona è lei a fare
l'azione è lei ad interpretare il
segnale che produce è il cervello il
protagonista ci sono tanti problemi che
richiedono la nostra attenzione
l'ecologia la povertà il clima non
dobbiamo dimenticarci di dare anche le
nostre attenzioni alla tecnologia da
sviluppare per il bambino non vedente a
nessuno di noi piace stare sospeso
dobbiamo dare tutto il supporto
necessario ai bambini non vedenti
perché anche loro riescano come noi ad
avere un bel primo ricordo della loro
infanzia